5 13 any friday morning hundreds of high
school kids from around the state just
wrapped up the 2021 kids vention
love seeing over 500 votes on this one
convention is a non-political political
convention where students debate issues
of our time with nevada lawmakers like
should the united states end the use of
the penny
jordan rank from green valley high
school said yes in 2020 it cost the u.s
mint nearly two cents to produce a
single penny while state assembly woman
robin titus said no support my little
seven-year-old granddaughter's learning
process when she has to count how many
censors in 25 cents by gosh grandma gave
her 25 pennies jamie malorney from the
state education department directed the
kids ventioneers to vote using an online
app and vote they did oh my gosh
so many students for almost a 400.
the students have decided that they
don't think we should keep the penny
nevada first lady kathy sisselak had
encouraging words for the students
who here loves nevada raise your hands
you can hear it as it whispers had a
music video treat from the thurman white
middle school choir singing
let freedom ring by the late great
george dair
[Music]
one of the driving forces behind kids
vention retired state senator joyce
woodhouse couldn't have been happier
with the way the virtual event went last
year we didn't have anything at all and
so this year we said okay let's try to
do this virtually i've been sitting here
crying for the last hour and a half
about how wonderful our elected
officials are debaters are our singers
are so just from the bottom of my heart
thank you all so very much
very cool and holding the event over
zoom actually allowed 10 of nevada's 17
counties to participate in learning the
value of civic engagement i can't thank
joyce and the entire kidsvention team
for inviting me to be the host now if
you know something that's cool at school
let us know on our website 8news.com
look for the community tab that's where
you'll find cool at school or you can
send us an email cool at school at
eightnewsnow.com what a cool thing this
kid's vention was that was awesome it
really does sound like it so the pennies
out huh the kids
there are three other debate topics they
also wanted to talk about whether we
should limit the population growth of
nevada to save our water supply they
said no we should not do that they also
said
should we limit access of teens to
social media to prevent bullying and
they actually surprisingly said no we
want to keep our access to social media
then they debated should we have free
college for our students and they
actually said no really it was
interesting to see because the state
lawmakers were saying yeah we should do
some of these things and then we could
say no i don't we don't think so
interesting yeah i mean great
perspective from you know absolutely
we talked about how the spec there's
going to be a special session today well
we already had it it was with names of
kids
they solved everything yeah
the real assembly is over at all the
high schools there you go i love that it
was a non-political political convention
exactly no politics in the political
convention